at some point the leader of the team
Alex kipman came to us and say so we
want to do a new controller but if you
just spoke to the machine made gestures
and we could recognize everything you
see that sounds like sci-fi and then we
said no wait a second but to detect
gestures we need specialized computer
vision we've been doing computer vision
for 15 years to identify your voice we
need speech recognition we've also been
doing speech recognition for 15 years oh
but now there may be other sounds and
multiple people oh but just a little
over 10 years ago we started these
microphone arrays they are acoustic
antennas you see wait a second we
actually have all the core elements we
could actually do this thing you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using
[Music]
from his deep technical roots as a
principal researcher and founder of the
communications collaboration and signal
processing group at MSR through his
tenure as managing director of the lab
in Redmond to his current role as
distinguished engineer chief scientist
for Microsoft Research and manager of
the MSR next enable group dr. Rico Malvo
has seen and pretty well done at all
today dr. Melva recalls his early years
at a fledgling Microsoft Research talks
about the exciting work he oversees now
explains why designing with the user is
as important as designing for the user
and tells us how a challenge from an
ex-football player with ALS led to a
prize-winning hackathon project and
produced the core technology that allows
you to type on a keyboard without your
hands and drive a wheelchair with your
eyes that and much more on this episode
of the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Rico mal VAR welcome to the podcast it's
a pleasure to be with you Gretchen
you're a distinguished engineer and
chief scientist at Microsoft Research
how would you define your current role
what gets you up in the morning ha ha
yeah bye chief scientists it means I
tell everybody what to do very simple
yeah not really
but chief scientist is basically a way
for me to have my fingers and eyes in
particular on everything going on at
Microsoft Research so I have an
opportunity to interact with essentially
all the labs many of the groups and find
opportunities to do collaborative
projects and that is really super
exciting and it's really hard to be on
top of what everybody is doing is quite
the opposite of telling people what to
do is like trying to follow up what
they're doing it's some level herding
cats
even herding is where are they find the
can see well talk a little bit about
your role as a distinguished engineer
what does that entail what does that
mean that's basically there is a whole
set of us we have distinguished
engineers and technical fellows which
are at the top of our technical ladder
and the idea is a little bit recognition
of some of the contributions we've done
in the technical area but it's mostly
our responsibility to go after big
technical problems and don't think just
about the group you're in but think
about the company what the company needs
what the technology in a particular area
should be evolving my area in particular
on the technical side is signal
processing data compression media
compression and these days without in
video engineering the internet that
matters a lot but also a few other areas
but that's the idea the idea is that
what are the big problems in technology
how can we drive new things
how can watch out for new things coming
up at the company level you know those
two things that you mentioned drive
things and anticipate things are two
kind of different gears and two
different wants a skill sets but maybe
it's happy
your brain in two places you're right
it's not completely different skillsets
but driving and following are both
important and one helps the other and
it's very important for us to do both
let's go back to your roots a little bit
when you started here at Microsoft
Research you were a principal researcher
and the founder and manager of what was
called the communications collaboration
and signal processing group at MSR so
tell us a little bit about the work you
used to do and give us a short where are
they now snapshot of that group yeah
that name is funny that name was a bad
example when you get to democratic about
choosing names and then we got everybody
in the team to give ideas and then it
got all complicated and we end up with a
little bit of everything and came up
with a boring name instead of a cool but
it was a very descriptive name is was
good it was just called signal
processing when we started and then it
evolved to communication collaboration
and signal processing because of the new
things we were doing for example we had
a big project on the collaboration area
which is the prototype of a system which
later evolved to become the round table
product and that's not just signal
processing it's not elaboration we have
to put collaboration but people use it
to communicate so it's also
communication say ok put it all in the
name so it's just like that and on your
question of where people are a cool
thing is that we had a combination of
expertise in the team to be able to do
things like round tables so we had
computer vision experts we had
distributed systems experts we had
streaming media experts and we had audio
experts on the last one for example an
audio then later we actually evolved a
new group doing specifically audio
signal processing which has now led by
Yvonne tishell who was a member of my
team and now has his own team he already
participated in your podcast so it's
nice to see the interesting challenges
in those areas continue and we keep
evolving as you know the groups are
always changing modifying we
in fact that leads into my next question
Microsoft Research as an entity has
evolved quite a bit since it was formed
in 1991 and you were managing director
in the mid 2000s from like 2007 to 2010
10 off that lab here in Redmond yeah so
tell us a little bit about the history
of the organization in the time you've
been here yeah it's great one thing I
really like about Microsoft Research is
first is that it started early with the
top leaders in the company always
believing in the concept so Bill Gates
started Microsoft Research driven by
Nathan Myhrvold a CTO at the time and it
was a no-brainer for them to start
Microsoft research they found Rick
ratchet who was our first leader of NSR
then I had the pleasure of reporting to
Rick for many years and the vision he
put in is still to this day is let's
really push the limits of technology we
don't start by thinking how this is
gonna help mind herself we start by
thinking how we push the technology how
it helps people later we will figure out
how it's gonna help Microsoft and to
this date that's how we operate with the
difference being maybe is that in the
old days the lab was more of a classical
research lab almost everything was
pivoted on research projects which is
great and many many of them generated
good technology or even new products so
help me I was just talking about round
table is one yeah example and we have
several of course the vast majority fail
because research is a business of
failure and we all know that we submit
10 papers for publication two or three
get accepted that is totally fine and we
keep playing the game and we do the
papers as a validation and also as a way
to interact with the community and both
are extremely valued to us so that we
can have a better understanding of our
push in the state-of-the-art in today
the new Microsoft Research puts even a
little more emphasis on the impact side
we still want to push the
state-of-the-art we still do innovative
things but we want to spend a little
more effort on making those things real
yeah on helping the company
and even the company itself evolved to a
point where that has even a higher value
from Satya our CEO down it is the
mission of the company to empower people
to do more but empowering is not just
developing the technology is packaging
it shipping it in the right way making
products that actually leverage that so
I would say the new MSR gets even more
into ok what it takes to make this real
well let's talk a little bit about
Microsoft Research next give our
listeners what I would call your
elevator pitch of Microsoft next what
does it stand for how does it fit in the
portfolio of Microsoft Research I kind
of liken it to pick up basketball only
with scientists and more money but you
do it more justice than I do that's
funny
yeah next is actually a great idea as I
said we're always evolving and then when
Peter Lee came in and also Harry Shum is
our new leader they thought hard about
diversifying the approaches in which we
do research so we still have the
Microsoft research labs the part that is
a bit more traditional in the sense that
the research is mostly pivoted by areas
we have a graphics team natural language
processing group human-computer
interaction systems and so for many many
of them when you go to the next the idea
is different one way to achieve
potentially even more impact is pivot
some of those activities not by area but
by project by impact go oh because of
this technology and that technology
maybe we have an opportunity to do X
where X is this new project oh but we're
gonna have the first technology as
computer vision the other one is
hardware architectures oops we're gonna
have to need people in all those areas
together in a project team and then
purely has been driving that always
trying to find disruptive high-impact
things so that we can take new
challenges and lots of things are coming
up from this new model which we call
next which is new experiences in
technology I actually didn't know that
what the acronym stood for I saw what's
next
buzz of course is it that is a cool
acronym Peter did a much better job than
we did on the CCSP thing I love well
let's talk about enable the group
there's a fascinating story of how this
all got started and it involves a former
football player and what's now called
the yearly hackathon tell us the story
that is exactly right it all started
when that famous football player ex
football player Steve Gleason still a
good partner of ours is still a
consultant to my team Steve is a totally
impressive person he got diagnosed with
ALS and ALS is a very difficult disease
because you basically lose mobility and
at some point in life your organs may
lose their ability to function so most
people actually don't survive ALS but
with some mitigations you can prolong a
little bit and technology can help Steve
actually we quote him saying until there
is a cure for ALS technology is the cure
this is very inspiring and he created a
foundation team Gleason that really does
a wonderful job securing resources and
distributing resources to people with
ALS they really really make a difference
in the community and he came to us
almost five years ago and we were toying
with the idea of creating this hackathon
which is a company-wide effort to create
hack projects and then in one of those
which actually the first time we did
which is in 2014 Steve told us you know
I guys I want to be able to do more in
particular I want to be able to argue
with my wife and play with my son so I
need to communicate and I need to move
my eyes is to work does eye tracking
thing might be the way to go do you want
to do something with that a hackathon
team really got inspired by the
challenge and within a very short period
of time they created an eye tracking
system where you look at the computer
and then there is a keyboard and you can
look at the keys and type at the
keys by looking and there is a play
button so you can compose sentences and
then speak out that's with your eyes and
they also created an interface where
they put buttons similar to a joystick
on the screen you look at those and the
wheelchair moves in the direction of
where you're selecting they did a nice
overlay between the buttons and the
video so it's almost like they put a
computer mounted on the wheelchair you
look through the computer the camera
shows what's in front of you and then
the wheelchair goes with lots of safety
things like a stop button it was very
successful that project in fact it won
the first prize on prize and then a
little bit later Peter and I were
thinking about where to go in new
projects and then Peter but he suggested
Rico what about that hackathon thing
that seems to be quite impactful so
maybe we want to develop that technology
further why do you think I say well if I
had a team we could do that how many
people you need I don't know six seven
to start nothing okay that's good to do
it it was as easy as that well let's
talk a little bit more about the
hackathon I'm like you said it's about
in its fifth year and as I understand it
it's kind of a ground-up approach such a
replaced the annual executive
inspirational talk top-down kind of
summer with my hey let's get the whole
company involved in invention I would
imagine it's had a huge impact on the
company at large but how would you
describe the role of the hackathon for
people in Microsoft Research now it
seems like a lot of really interesting
things have come out of that summer
event you know for us it was a clear
thing because Microsoft research was
always bottom-up I mean we literally
don't tell researchers what to do people
researchers engineers designers managers
they all have great ideas right and they
come up with those great ideas when they
click and off they start developing
something and we look from the top and
say that sounds good keep going right so
we tried to foster the most promising
ones but the idea of bottom-up was
already there yeah when we look at the
hackathon we see a thanks to Satya in
the new leadership of Microsoft the
what is embracing this concept of moving
autumn ah there's the garage the garage
has been involved with many of those
hackathons garage has been a driver and
supporter of the hackathon so to us it
was like a great that's how we work and
now we're gonna do more collaboration
with the rest of the company you have a
fantastic and diverse group of
researchers working with you many of
whom have been on the podcast already
and been delightful who and what does it
take to tackle big issues huge ideas
like hands-free keyboards and eye
tracking and 3d sound right one
important concept and it's particularly
important for enable is that we really
need to pay attention to the user terms
such as user centered yeah they sound
like cliche but especially in
accessibility this is super-important
for example and in our enable team the
area working with eye tracking our in
mainly intended user were people with
ALS
since the motivation from Steve Gleason
and then in our team in Paradiso who
gives our user experience manager she
created what we call the Powell's
program paws means person with ALS and
we actually brought people with ALS in
their wheelchairs and everything to our
lab and discussed ideas with them so
they were not just testers they were
brainstorming with us on the design
collaboration was just collaborators
they loved doing it they really felt wow
I'm in this condition but I can
contribute to something meaningful and
we will make it better for the next
generation of people with this so this
concept of strong user understanding
through user design and user research
particularly on accessibility makes a
big difference mm-hmm talk a little bit
about the technical side of things what
kinds of technical lines of inquiry are
you really focusing on right now I think
our listeners are really curious about
what they're studying and how that might
translate over here if they wanted to
that that's a great question mainly
of the advancements today are associated
with artificial intelligence
because of all the applications of the
eye including in our projects ai is
typically a bunch of algorithms and data
manipulation in finding patterns and
data and so forth but AI itself doesn't
talk to the user you still need the last
mile of the interfaces the new interface
is the AI gonna appear to the user as a
voice or something on the screen how is
the user going to interact with the AI
so we need new interfaces and then with
the evolution of technology we can
develop novel interfaces eye tracking
being an example if I tell you that
you're gonna control your computer with
your eyes you're gonna say what what
does that mean if I tell you gonna
control the computer with your voice you
say oh yeah I've been doing that for a
while
we'll be eye tracking for a person with
disability they immediately get it and
they say aha I know what it means and I
want to use that for everybody
suppose for example that you're having
your lunch break and you want to browse
the news on the internet get up-to-date
on a topic of interest but you eating a
sandwich your hands are busy your mouth
is busy but your eyes are free you could
actually flip around pages do a lot of
things just with your eyes and you don't
need to worry about cleaning your hands
and touching the computer because you
don't need to touch the computer and you
can think in the future where you may
not even need your eyes I may read your
thoughts directly and at some point it's
just a matter of time it's not that far
away we're gonna read your thoughts
directly that's both exciting and scary
yes what does it take to say alright
we're gonna make a machine be able to
look at your eyes and tell you back what
you're doing yeah you see it's the
specialized version of computer vision
it's basically cameras that look at your
eyes in fact the sensor works by first
illuminating your eyes with bright IR
lights
infrareds so it doesn't bother you
because you can't see but now you have
this bright image that the cameras
looking at IR can see and then models
and a little bit of AI in a little
of just graphics and computer vision and
signal modeling that then make an
estimate of the position of your eyes
and associate that with elements on the
screen so it's almost as if you have a
cursor on the screen okay that is
control with your eyes very similar to a
mouse with the difference that the eye
control works better if we don't display
the cursor with the mouse you actually
should display the cursor with I control
the cursors works better if it is
invisible but you see the idea there is
that you do need specialists you need
folks who understand that and sometimes
you do a combination of some of that
understanding being in the group so we
need to be the top leaders in that
technology or we partner with partners
that have a piece of the technology for
example for the eye tracking we put much
more emphasis on designing the proper
user interfaces and user experiences
because there are companies that do a
good job in producing eye tracking
devices so we leverage the eye tracking
devices that these companies produce and
behind that you're building on machine
learning technologies on computer vision
technologies and example a typical one
is that the keyboard driven by your eyes
you still want to have a predictive
keyboard sure so as you're typing the
letters it guesses but how you interface
on the guest it's very interesting
because when you're typically using a
keyboard your eye is looking at the
letters your fingers are typing in the
keys when you're doing an eye control
keyboard your eye has to do everything
so how you design the interface should
be different and we've learned in design
good ways of make that different if I'm
looking at the screen and I'm moving my
eyes how does it know when I'm done you
know like that's the letter I want I
just that laser beam de you you said you
would be asking deep technical questions
in you are that one we use the concept
that we call dwelling as you look around
the keyboard remember that I told you we
don't display the cursor right but as
you're the position where you look in
your eyes
the focus of your eye is in a particular
letter we highlight that letter it can
be a different color it can be a lighter
shade that's right so as you move around
you see the letters moving around if you
want to type a particular letter once
you get to that letter you stop moving
for a little bit let's say half a second
that's a dwell you dwell on that letter
a little bit and we measure it as well
and there's a little bit of AI to learn
what is the proper time based on the
user
one thing I'm fascinated by not just
here but in scientific ventures
everywhere is the research success story
the one that chronicles the path of a
blue sky research thing to instantiation
and a product and I know over and over
researchers told me research is
generally a slow business so it's not
like oh the overnight success story but
there's a lot of hard-won success
stories or stories that sort of
blossomed over multiple years of
serendipitous discovery do you have any
stories that you could share about
things that you've seen that started out
like a harebrained idea and now millions
of people are using you know there is so
many examples I particularly like the
story of Connect which was actually not
a product developed by Microsoft
Research but in close collaboration with
Microsoft Research it was the connect
team at the time in Windows because at
some point the leader of the team Alex
kipman came to us and says oh we want to
do a new controller but if you just
spoke to the machine made gestures and
we could recognize everything you see
that sounds like sci-fi so now that
doesn't work but then alex was very
insistent and then we said no wait a
second but to detect gestures we need
specialized computer vision we've been
doing computer vision for 15 years to
identify your voice we need speech
recognition we've also been doing speech
recognition for 15 years oh but now
there may be other sounds and there may
be multiple people oh but just a little
over 10 years ago we started these
microphone arrays they are acoustic
antennas they can tune to the sound
whoever is doing all of that the
directional sound inputs let's see wait
a second we actually have all the core
elements we could actually do this thing
so after the third or fourth meeting you
say okay Alex I think we can do that and
say great you have two years to do it
what because we need to ship at this
particular day and it all worked I doubt
there's some other institution or a
company that could have produced that
because we've been doing what was
apparently blue sky
for many years but then we created all
those technologies and when the need
arose they say aha we can put them all
together where is connect today Connect
used to be a peripheral device for Xbox
we changed it into an IOT device so
there's a new Kinect kit connects to
Azure so people can do connect like
things not just for games but for
everything and all the technology that
supports that is now in Azure Sirico you
have a reputation for being an optimist
you've actually said as much yourself
plus you work with teams on projects
that are actually making the lives of
people with disabilities and others
profoundly better but I know some of the
projects that you worked on fall
somewhere in the bounds of medical
interventions mm-hmm so is there
anything about what you do that keeps
you up at night anything we should be
concerned about yeah you know when
you're helping a person with disability
sometimes what you doing can be seen as
is that a treatment is that a medical
device in most cases they are not but
the answer to those questions can be
complicated and there can be regulations
and of course Microsoft is a super
responsible company and if anything is
regulated of course we're going to pay
attention to the regulations but some of
those are complex so doing it right by
the regulations can take significant
amount of work so we have to do this
extra work so my team has to spend time
sometimes in collaboration with our
legal team to make sure we do the right
things and I hope also that we will help
evolve those regulations potentially by
working with the regulatory bodies
educating them on the evolution of the
technology because in all areas not just
this area but almost all areas of
Technology regulations tend to be behind
it's hard to move and understandably so
so the fact that we have to spend
significant effort dealing with that
does keep me up at night a little bit
but we do our best you know there's a
bit of a Wild West mentality where you
have to like you say educate and so in a
sense what I hear you saying
that as you take responsibility for what
you're doing you're helping to shape and
inform the way the culture on boards
these things exactly right yes so
exactly how would you sort of frame that
for people out there how do we you
helped move the culture into a space
that more understands what's going on
and can on board it with
responsibilities themselves that is a
great question and you see for example
in areas such as AI artificial
intelligence people are naturally afraid
of how far can I go
why are kinds of things it could do can
we regulate so that there will be some
control in how it's developed and
Microsoft has taken the stance that we
have to be very serious about AI we have
to be ethical we have to preserve
privacy and all of those things so
instead of waiting for regulation and
regulatory aspects to develop let's help
them so we were founders of not just me
but the company especially the Microsoft
Research AI team founders of the
partnership for AI in partnership with
other companies to actually say now
let's be proactive about that
[Music]
tell us a bit about Rico mell VAR let's
go further back then your time here at
MSR and tell us how you got interested
in technology technology research how
did you end up here at Microsoft
Research okay on the first question how
I got interested in technology took me a
long time I think I was eight years old
when my dad gave me an electronics kit
and I start playing with that thing and
I say aha that's why I want to do when I
grow up so then I went through high
school taking courses in electronics
then I went to college to become an
electrical engineer and I loved the
academic environment I love doing
research so I knew I wanted to do grad
school I got lucky enough to be accepted
at MIT and when I arrived there it's
like boy this place is tough and it was
tough but then when I finished I went
back to my home country I created a
signal processing group at the school
there which was I was lucky to get fair
amounts of funding so we did lots of
cool things and then one day some our
colleagues in a company here in the US
call me back in Brazil and they say eh
our director of research decided to do
something else do you want to apply for
the position and then I told my wife a
there's a job opening in the US what
about that and say well go talk to them
and I can talk to them they make me an
offer and then it took us a whole month
discussing are we gonna move our whole
family to another country we live there
before it's not so bad because I studied
here and maybe it's gonna be good for
the kids let's go if something doesn't
work we move back I see okay so and here
we are and but that was not Microsoft
that for another company at the time a
company called picture tell which was
actually the leading company in
professional video conferencing systems
so we were pushing the state-of-the-art
on how do you compress video and audio
and these other things and I was working
happily there for about four years and
then one day I see Microsoft and I say
wow Microsoft Research is growing fast
then one afternoon I said ok I think
about it and I sent an email to the CTO
Microsoft saying you guys are great you
developing all these groups you don't
have you had a group on signal
processing and signal processing is
important because one day we're gonna be
watching video on your computers via the
internet and all of that so you should
be investing more on that and I see you
already have Windows Media Player
anyways if you want to do research and
signal processing here's my CD I could
build and lead a group for you doing
that and then I tell my wife and she
goes you did what was Nathan Miravalle
Nathan and she said man I see what do I
have to lose the worst case they don't
respond and life is good I have a good
job here it's all good and that wasn't a
Sunday afternoon Monday morning I get an
email from Microsoft hey my name is
Suzanne I work on recruiting I'm
coordinating your interview trip and I
said alright and then I show the email
to my life it was like what it works and
then actually it was a great time the
environment here from day one since the
interviews the openness of everybody's
management possibilities and the desire
of Microsoft - yeah let's explore this
area this area one big word here is
diversity diversity of people diversity
of areas it is so broad and that's super
exciting so I was almost think whatever
offer they made me I'll take it
fortunately they made a reasonable one
so it wasn't too hard to make that
decision well two things I take away
from what you've just told me you keep
using the word lucky and I think that
has less to do with it then you're
making it out to be because there's a
lot of really smart people here that say
I was so lucky that they offered me it's
like no they're lucky to have you
actually but also the idea that if you
don't ask you're never gonna know
whether you could have or not I think
that's a wonderful story of boldness and
saying why not yeah any fad boldness is
very characteristic of Microsoft
Research we're not afraid we have an
idea we just go and execute and we're
fortunate I know against a lucky as a
fortunate that we're in a company that
sees that and gives us the resources to
do so
Rico I like to ask all my guests as we
come to the end of our conversation to
offer some parting thoughts to our
listeners I think what you've just said
is a fantastic parting thought but maybe
there's more so what advice or wisdom
would you pass on to what we might call
the next generation of technical
researchers what's important for them to
know what qualities should they be
cultivating in their lives in work in
order to be successful in this arena I
would go back on boldness and diversity
boldness you've already highlighted
Gretchen that you know if you have an
idea but it's not just to roughen idea
you know a singer too wide that actually
could work go after it give it a try
especially if you're young don't worry
if you fail many things I fail many
things in my life but what matters is
not the failures you learn from the
failures and you do it again and the
other one is diversity always think
diversity in all the dimensions all
kinds of people everywhere in the world
doesn't matter gender race ethnicity
upbringing rich poor whatever they come
from everybody can have cool ideas the
person whom you least expects to invent
something might be the one inventing so
listen to everybody because that
diversity is great and remember the
diversity of users don't assume that all
users are the same go learn what users
really think if you're not sure if I dia
or idea B is the better go talk to them
try them out tasks to get their opinion
test things with them so push diversity
on both sides diversity on the creation
and diversity on who's gonna use your
technology and don't assume you know in
fact Satya has been pushing the whole
company towards that put us in a growth
mindset which basically means keep
learning right because then if you do
that that diversity will expand and then
we'll be able to do more rico Mel var
I'm so glad that I finally got you on
the podcast it's been delightful thanks
for joining us today it has been a
pleasure thanks for inviting me
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Rico Malabar and
how research for people with
disabilities is enabling people of all
abilities visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]